bonsoir christophe chira merci d'être
avec nous on imagine que vous avez fait
grise mine en entendant cette
information relayée par nos confrères
d'rtl sera a priori officiel cette
semaine mais vous vous attendiez vous à
un tel repas oui bien sûr on s'attendait
à un tel report absolument n'avais
aucune illusion sur le fait qu'on
n'allait pas rouvrir le 20 janvier alors
aujourd'hui quel est votre état d'esprit
vous vous y attendiez mais voilà vous
êtes quoi résigné en colère non n'est
certainement pas résignés on est très en
colère évidemment puisque finalement on
est utilisé par ce gouvernement pour
masquer quelque part c'est incompétence
et son incapacité à gérer cette crise et
du coup ça devient très pénible parce
que les conséquences vont être vraiment
dramatique sans plan social au niveau de
nok de nos collègues pas seulement les
restaurateurs à même les commerçants
sont sont très ennuyée donc évidemment
on est extrêmement en colère brillant
combien m ce gouvernement face à ses
responsabilités parce que trop c'est
trop et on peut pas laisser comme ça
tous les mois nous fermer nos jours y
recense avoir mon vin c'est pas possible
est ce qu'aujourd'hui finalement vous
sentez le soutien de la population
française parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet extrêmement compliqué on est
peut-être à la veille d'une troisième
vague
voilà tout le monde se disent ça nous
embête tous d'avoir les restaurants
fermés mais dans le même temps la
situation est compliquée clairement vous
vous sentez soutenu par les populations
on se sent soutenu oui bien sûr c'est à
dire que la population comme vous dites
commence à comprendre aussi les disques
on comprend d'où nous on va un petit peu
plus vite parce qu'on y est confronté du
matin au soir
mais bien sûr tout le monde commence à
comprendre que toutes ces mesures n'ont
finalement pas tellement déchets ou pas
d'effet du tout nous ne resterons n'ont
jamais été des zones de contamination
telle qu'on veut bien au charme
doulchard fois c'est pas vrai personne
ne l'a testé c'est pas vrai et bien sûr
que les gens commencent maintenant à
comprendre beaucoup se disent quelque
chose cloche parce que finalement on a
accepté toutes ces mesures
et puis pour autant comme vous dites
d'ailleurs vous même on est on est alors
à la veille d'une troisième vague alors
où est le problème exactement dans ce
pays qu'est-ce qui se passe
exactement on sait pas mais ça vient pas
de nous finalement c'est s'offrira pour
vous finalement quelle est la pire en
justice dans cette affaire c'est vrai
que certains restaurateurs parle des
écoles ouvertes avec des comptines
d'autres voilà qui commentait cette
scène avec cette miss rose dans le sens
d'un centre commercial avec des
personnes voilà certes masqué mais pas
toujours
quelle est la pire des choses finalement
pour vous restaurateur aujourd'hui
écoutez moi je vous dirais très
honnêtement que la pire des choses c'est
pas ce qui se passe c'est ce qui se
passe pas ma foi s'il ya un peu de vie
quelque part dans ce pays je suis pas
certain que ce soit à blâmer
nous sommes les seules choses qui répare
une injustice c'est d'une part ce qui se
passe pas c'est que nous soyons la
variable d'ajustement est petit commerce
voilà les petits établissements et pas
les grands comme bic qui sont pour le
coup certainement des endroits à forte
hausse de risque de contamination par ce
que tout le monde sait que tout alors
évidemment ça c'est une injustice et le
deuxième à justice et la différence de
traitement entre tous les commerçants au
titre de ce fameux fonds de solidarité
qui n'est pas du tout équitable qui et
qui va faire des délais shalit en très
grand nombre dans les mois qui viennent
et ça ça va être une catastrophe qu'on
peut nous dire tout ce qu'on veut que la
france mais des milliards et des
milliards
les bains la france elle ne met pas les
milliards là où il le faut elle ne met
pas pour tout le monde en tout cas et ça
ça va pas du tout non plus et du coup
nous on engage une procédure très
officiellement pour obtenir une
indemnisation des pertes et non pas des
aides
parce que les choses doivent être justes
elles doivent pas être décidées comme ça
avec des forfaits qu'on donne à qui on
veut ou à qui ont peu ou à qui on décide
dans un tableau excel ça va pas du tout
il ya un vrai problème d'équité dans le
traitement de soutien aux commerçants et
aux restaurateurs
du coup le gouvernement qui doit
annoncer des dispositifs dead prolonger
autant que nécessaire en disent ils
c'est prendre le problème dans le
mauvais sens selon vous c'est prendre le
problème dans le mauvais sens c'est à
dire que même le gouvernement décide de
nous charmer
on nous a pas demandé notre avis et
quand on le donne tout le monde s'en
fout et quand on expliquer que l'on
produit des éléments pour dire que chez
nous les choses se passent bien et qu'on
est des gens sérieux
tout le monde s'en fout alors trêve
le gouvernement décide de nous maintenir
charme et donc que le gouvernement
assume et qu'on arrête de nous parler
des aides on veut pas d aide nous on n'a
rien demandé donc combien pas d r on n'a
jamais demandé del sûr mais des
indépendants c'est bien parce qu'on est
indépendant et qu'on veut le rester
malheureusement nous en empêche donc la
moindre des choses c'était effectivement
qu'on en soit indemnisée n'est pas aidé
c'est une vraie indemnisation dont on a
besoin
les conséquences sont dramatiques nos
fonds de commerce ne valent plus rien ça
va au delà du chiffre d'affaires perdu
aujourd'hui clairement il ya beaucoup de
scepticisme
évidemment dans le pays on le sait quant
au vaccin mais voilà beaucoup de
spécialistes pensent que c'est la seule
solution évidemment pour s'en sortir
quand vous voyez la lenteur du des
vaccinations dans le pays ça vous
inspire quoi encore plus d'inquiétude
bah écoutez moi je n'ai pas à me
prononcer sur le vote si je suis pas un
scientifique donc évidemment que ce
vaccin fait beaucoup parler en tout cas
si comme vous le dites beaucoup de
spécialistes disent que c'est la seule
solution effectivement on doit vraiment
se poser une question sur la rapidité de
sa mise en oeuvre et sur les conditions
logistiques de de son déploiement
moi j'en sais rien je suis pas un
spécialiste moi je fais des entrecôtes
vous savez donc moi comme j'ai des
entrecôtes affaire je dis pas à mes
clients de venir dans droite dans trois
jours les manger je l'achète je devrais
bientôt virus disparaisse pour qu'on
puisse manger vos entrecôte vont cher
christophe h ira bien bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr mais on verra bien ce moment là
il faut effectivement que encore une
fois toujours les mêmes le gouvernement
fasse son boulot ne je veux dire je sais
pas moi s'ils savent pas déployé le truc
il faut qu'ils demandent à leurs amis de
d'amazon ou juste parce qu'ils ont des
chaînes de logistique apparemment on
sait pas d'où ça c'est pas notre
problème en vérité très bien si ce
vaccin fonctionne et 6 900 permet
d'éradiquer le virus qui a priori ne
sont pas être le cas quand on écoute
effectivement les scientifiques qu'il
dit ce qu on sait même pas si on va
rester contaminants pas contaminantes ça
devient assez compliqué cette histoire
mais nous elle nous regarde pas ça
nous on veut travailler et essayer on va
pas nous mettre sous cloche pendant
encore des mois en attendant les
résultats d'un de d échelle d'un vaccin
qu'on n'a même pas encore mis en route
on marche sur la tête on marche on
appelle ce soir le royaume uni a décidé
de reconfirmer totalement
pour deux semaines ça vous inspire quoi
une grande inquiétude également pour
notre pays
le royaume-uni a décidé j'ai vu que les
causes les décidé aussi pour tout le
mois de janvier ça devient une habitude
maintenant vous rendez compte c'est une
habitude c'est à dire qu'on recompte
chine maintenant comme on va acheter le
pain est bien reconstruit les gens
pourraient donner la priorité à autre
chose sans doute merci christophe chira
restaurateurs représentants du collectif
les pendus merci d'avoir été avec nous
et bon courage à vous